irán llegado a un acuerdo con la agencia
nuclear de la onu para darle más
tranquilidad al mundo sobre sus alcances
permitiendo que inspectores del
organismo internacional de energía
atómica reactiva en cámaras de
vigilancia ubicadas en sus centrales
nucleares
y la continuidad de las operaciones del
equipo de la agencia es indispensable
para nosotros para brindar las garantías
necesarias y la información al organismo
y al mundo de que todo está en orden y
que vamos a poder ayudar
además para ayudar a irán en sus futuras
negociaciones en el contexto del plan de
acción integral conjunto el acuerdo
llega con el fin de evitar un
enfrentamiento diplomático sin embargo
la decisión no convence del todo a la
agencia de la onu teherán no dijo si
entregará copias de las grabaciones con
las que amenazó previamente diciendo que
las destruiría
acordamos que para el cambio de las
tarjetas de memoria de las cámaras de
vigilancia el equipo técnico relacionado
vendrá a irán después del acuerdo para
que puedan hacer las medidas técnicas
necesarias para las cámaras y las
tarjetas de memoria pero según el
acuerdo de salvaguardias las tarjetas
antiguas serán selladas y guardadas en
irán
en julio de 2015 irán y seis potencias
mundiales llegaron a un histórico
acuerdo que limitaba el programa nuclear
iraní a cambio del levantamiento de
sanciones económicas en 2018 eeuu bajo
la presidencia de donald trump se retiró
de dicho acuerdo y le impuso los
castigos a iran la república islámica
respondió incumpliendo muchas de las
restricciones del acuerdo enriqueciendo
uranio a una pureza más alta y
acercándose cada vez más al nivel
adecuado para fabricar armas nucleares
se espera que la próxima semana se
reúnan los representantes de la agencia
nuclear de la onu para decidir si
presionar más a irán a través de una
resolución que no obstante pondría en
peligro la reanudación de las
negociaciones en viena